you know it's interesting also what you
said about the cultural aspect of it
whether we as people want to go to this
metaverse with Zuckerberg or not versus
the company that just has to Pivot
because nobody's paying attention to
Facebook anymore it's like man just
watch Ready Player one or read the book
and then decide do you want to follow
Mark Zuckerberg into that world and uh I
think probably the three of us have the
same answer to that one uh just a little
bit more on some of the cuts that are
happening in the industry this is from
Bloomberg at Twitter and Jeffrey you
reference this the diversity equity and
inclusion team is down to just two
people from 30. uh one former employee
said a Dei worker who was let go from a
popular ride share company said that
their job search has stalled as other
technology companies assess their
finances and just before getting the
acts at separate Tech Giants this fall
two Dei Specialists said leadership had
stopped setting long-term goals for
their departments entirely the layoffs
sweeping the technology industry are
gutting diversity and inclusion
departments threatening company pledges
to boost underrepresented groups in
their ranks and Leadership listings for
Dei roles were down 19 percent last year
a bigger decline than legal or general
Human Resources jobs saw according to
findings from text to which helps
companies create unbiased job ads only
software engineering and data science
jobs saw larger larger declines at 24
and 27 percent respectively uh you know
I can tell you guys having started
locals and obviously merged with Rumble
the idea that we would be sitting down
in the hiring process and I'm personally
not that involved with with the hiring
but I am involved in policy
and how we go about doing public-facing
business the idea that we would be
looking at engineers and going you're a
lesbian and you're black and you have a
lazy eye is so bananas but that's I
guess why we will build great products
and why Jeffrey as you said Elon had to
fire half the company when he bought the
when he way overpaid for a very faulty
product yeah yeah uh look at those
statistics just make me so happy you
know and there's not a lot of happiness
in the world but but but watching you
know the euthanasia of the over class
you know embedded in this in HR Dei and
ESG and all that stuff is just a source
of immense joy for me I just I I have to
say there's that like say so says you
you white guy
it's but the thing is that all these
divisions are not really about
stockholders they're not really about
company performance they're not about
profitability and it would just be nice
to see uh companies get back to what
they're supposed to be doing just
bringing value to the customers and
value to the stockholders that would be
a nice thing all this stuff happened as
Vivek said over the last 15 years when
we massively distorted production
structures with Ben bernanke's Fancy
Pants trick to get us out of the housing
crisis in 2008 it wrecked American
capitalism was We Know It direct
everything it was a huge cultural cost
and at the time I didn't really quite
understand what was about to happen
we've lived through a decade and a half
of growing nonsense that's finally being
cut down to size I hope we're just
beginning that process it's absolute
Delight to see this if you'd like more
sane takes on our insane World check out
our direct message clips playlist and if
you want to watch more full episodes of
our live round tables watch our round
tables playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell